♪♪
Neil Cross:
I think about every episode as
being a different
chapter in a travel narrative.
♪♪
So what do I do?
Go left.
Right here.
Allie:
HERE!
(Tires squealing)
Rupert Wyatt:
The book itself is, is very
patriarchal
because the main character is
not the most empathetic of
individuals and
Rupert Wyatt:
he's somebody who wants to sort
of rip his family away
Rupert Wyatt:
from the clutches of the 20th
century and all of it's commercialism
and materialism and take them to
a new Eden.
We're gonna chase the weather
out in Mexico.
To where?
Mexico. Sip some tequila. Go
swimming. Go fishing.
You don't eat enough fish, you
need to eat more fish.
We don't even know anyone there.
The tv show employs this couple,
this family of four, not making
a choice to leave
Rupert Wyatt:
but they're on the run.
(Door shatters)
Justin Theroux:
Neil Cross is the shepherd and
guardian for the scripts,
he came up with a really good
device of basically knowing that
there needed to be
Justin Theroux:
something at the backs of the
foxes, meaning this government
Justin Theroux:
agency that is sort of chasing
them out of the United States.
♪♪
Police:
Spread out!
Let's go.
♪♪
Rupert Wyatt:
Visually what we tried to do was
to show that
two very different worlds. One
that was very clean and
fluorescent,
Rupert Wyatt:
and then an outside world, in
the case of where they're headed
Rupert Wyatt:
that was much more unordered,
unpredictable.
Rupert Wyatt:
The colors more of a kind of
blend of different influences
Rupert Wyatt:
and sources.
♪♪
We're, more often than not,
quick to judge what a migrant is
Rupert Wyatt:
and in this instance it's a
white, nuclear, American family
Rupert Wyatt:
going into a wholly different
culture.
♪♪
We take them from "this is their
environment, this is their life"
and we take it all away from
them.
We gotta go!
♪♪